so today we're going to talk about darkened skin
spots what's behind that now the medical term
for that is called melasma so here we have an
overactive melanocyte which is making too much
melanin which is the pigment so it's going to
show up in a slightly darkened area on your skin
and there are three main causes one would be high
levels of insulin or insulin resistance and this
is why you see this in cases with polycystic
ovarian syndrome all the time you see these
little skin spots all over what's behind that is
high insulin and if you're not familiar with pcos
the excess insulin is triggering the high
levels of androgen now the number two cause
is high levels of estrogen and this is why you
would see this in pregnancy or when someone took
hormone replacement therapy or birth control
pills and then the third cause would be stress
induced because the cortisol is too high and
there's two main adrenal conditions you have
cushing's syndrome and you have addison's disease
and so in addison's disease you would see these
darkened little skin spots throughout the
body now because stress can trigger this
too much sun can also give you these little spots
as well so it's really a matter of identifying
what's causing this if it's stress i would take
b vitamins and i would take more vitamin d3 if
the problem is high estrogen i would actually
recommend the person consume more cruciferous
vegetables and definitely some sea kelp and then
we have the insulin resistance which is probably
the most common cause and for that we recommend
healthy keto and intermittent fasting if you're
new to my channel i put the link down below of
exactly how to do it before you go if you have
a question about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto or you're
on keto and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth i have a keto consultant standing
by to help you this is just for the people in
the u.s hopefully in the future we'll be able
to answer everyone's call but i put the number
down below so you can call and get some help